welcome to our covet 19 special on dw
the coronavirus pandemic has had a big
impact on the lives of children in many
countries schools and daycare centers
have been closed but recent studies show
daycare centers could stay open without
problems but what about schools
[Music]
we'll also be visiting india and
indonesia where the rollout of booster
vaccines is underway
and we'll meet a scientist who's working
to develop a new vaccine in indonesia
shutting down daycare centers leads to a
host of problems
young children soon get bored when they
can't play with others
for parents it means children need to be
looked after at home
germany has not yet approved a vaccine
for children under the age of five but
despite that a new study suggests
daycare centers still don't need to
close because young children are better
protected than previously thought
[Music]
it's wednesday morning and the el
cavezno family are getting tested
twins niza and taha are four years old
they go to daycare
that means they have to be tested for
covert 19 twice a week
the little ones do not enjoy the
procedure
but testing helps ensure that daycare
centers can remain open
that's the conclusion reached by
scientists at the university of wurzburg
they conducted a study over a period of
several months using different methods
to test over 600 children as well as
their parents and daycare staff for
covert 19.
and what we found out that parents who
whose children were participating in
regular testing they felt bad about the
pandemic and about you know the
consequences of the pandemic they felt
more secure and their psychological
well-being was higher compared to
parents where the children did not
regularly participate in regular
testings
the scientists reached another
surprising conclusion
we almost could not find coronavirus
infection in children who were regularly
visiting our kindergarten and daycare
institutions so surprisingly the new
coronavirus did not spread
a lot
among
children
at the toddler age
and we think today this is due to
special conditions of the immune system
of children who have a very good
capacity of the the innate immunity
to defend the virus
on the mucosal surfaces and the
nasopharynx
unlike with adults pattern recognition
receptors on children's nasal mucosa are
highly active
they can recognize viruses early and
release messenger substances activating
a flurry of defense
reactions moreover healthy children have
more immune cells in their noses than
adults do
that allows them to take on viruses and
neutralize them more effectively
at the start of the pandemic day care
centers were seen as super spreader
sites and had to shut
it was hard for many children to adjust
to the new normal
they didn't understand why we
things are much better now
today nisa and taha have both tested
negative so it's off to daycare
parents can pick up free rapid antigen
tests at the center every week the study
shows that the approach is effective so
long as more than half the families go
along with it
most of the families accept it and
arrange amongst themselves who gets
tested when
the daycare centre has also switched to
smaller groups
each group has its own room
if one child tests positive the whole
group has to quarantine
the staff also make sure they abide by
social distancing and hygiene rules
parents have to say goodbye to their
kids at the door
we have bells now to make things as
cheerful as possible for the children
and they've responded well
we've introduced hand washing rituals
and the children sing songs while they
do it they enjoy playing with the water
there are 170 children in nisa and
taha's day care center in the past year
only one child has tested positive but
with the current rise in omicron cases
that may now change
the new virus variant will establish
more efficiently
in
the kindergarten age in the toddler age
and will spread out there more
efficiently
so nisa taha their parents and all the
other families will have to keep testing
for a while to come
closing day care centers and schools and
restricting social interaction can have
a negative effect on children's
emotional well-being and behaviour
our reporter hang chuen lee spoke to the
director of child and adolescent
psychiatry at innsbruck university's
medical center in austria
she's been studying the psychological
impact of the pandemic on children
many thanks for joining us my
you lead pleasure research project about
the effects of the pandemic on children
and adolescents in austria what are your
most important findings so far
we're looking at kindergarten children
and school children up to the age of 13.
so the focus is on younger children and
young adolescents
and to sum it up in a sentence the
emotional impact the sense of insecurity
they feel has clearly increased as a
result of all the changes that have been
happening
the main symptoms that we are seeing are
emotional changes more depressive moods
and anxiety issues more emotional
neediness the children's quality of life
is also suffering
what did you find out that really sticks
in your mind
i was upset by the fact that so many of
them spoke about their loneliness during
lockdown
it was really a tragedy for the children
and difficult for them to bear
emotionally that they were no longer
able to properly celebrate christmas
birthdays confirmation all of these key
family celebrations
and i was concerned about how much the
children were affected by the worries of
the adults
how will this impact jobs financial
payments and so forth
i found it upsetting how much they were
aware of these troubles
according to your study boys and girls
had very different symptoms why is that
at the start the boys were quicker to
manifest or externalize their symptoms
you notice it much more quickly when a
child is aggressive and doesn't stick to
the rules when they kick up a fuss than
when a child is withdrawn and quiet
and therefore less conspicuous
at the start it was the case that the
boys externalized their behavior much
more clearly than the girls
in the meantime there isn't any
perceptible gender difference both are
equally impacted
how much will children and adolescents
be affected by having to wear masks for
so long
i'm a child psychiatrist so i wouldn't
like to comment on the physical effects
of mask wearing but i can say something
about it in relation to my field
do children find it difficult to
interpret the emotions of their parents
or teachers
and luckily it's been confirmed in
scientific studies that children don't
have any significant difficulties
recognizing emotions
even if this part of your face is
covered you can still see the eyes and
hear the voice
so the children don't have any
difficulty interpreting the emotions of
their teachers or other adults who are
wearing masks
they know when they're furious or
annoyed
even if they're wearing masks
to what extent are these findings also
valid for children worldwide
is
i think that they are quite applicable
because there were restrictions hygiene
measures lockdowns school restrictions
social restrictions in other countries
too
and i think that how a child reacts to
these kinds of things is quite
transferable to other countries
it's understandable that children react
emotionally to it
it doesn't just pass them by
it has an emotional impact on them
what can parents and policymakers do to
counterbalance the psychological impact
on children
i think parents should take a very calm
and measured approach to the pandemic
explain lots
of course they should monitor how
children and adolescents are faring
emotionally
we know for example in another respect
that eating disorders have soared during
the pandemic
it's important that parents of
adolescent children watch for weight
loss
in my opinion schools could exercise
less pressure less stress about
schooling and could introduce subjects
like psychological health
children and adolescents could learn
something about stress and relaxation
i don't believe this is a lost or
psychologically disturbed generation but
i do think it's unstable at the moment
children and adolescents have been a bit
battered by what's happened so it's
vital to see what we can do to
counterbalance this
thank you
countries around the world closed their
schools for many months because of the
pandemic worldwide nearly 170 million
children were unable to attend school
for practically a whole year
but here in uganda schools were closed
for nearly two years
in march 2020 rising cases of covert 19
prompted the government to impose some
of africa's toughest restrictions
schools only finally reopened this month
after such a long time many students
lives have changed
and returning to the classroom is no
longer on the agenda
actually
we thought
that
the epidemic was going to take us a
month or a week i mean all two months
but
of course
we saw what happened
this lockdown kept on you know moving
expanding
up to now after almost two years
by the time we closed down we had about
300 children right now when we opened
the school not even 20 afternoon
you can't
come and say hi friend like
hug yourself that hey you're back to
school it feels bad but you're
protecting yourself
the pandemic has radically changed
students lives the number of child
pregnancies has risen
and many children have had to work to
help feed their families
local authorities estimate one-third of
students will never return to school
in germany many schools have long since
reopened but is that a good thing given
the number of infections right now
schools have been shown to be covert hot
spots which is why they were closed part
of the time last year but that meant
many students fell behind in their
studies
so this year things are to be handled
differently
but what's at stake
[Music]
media and the news that's the topic in
today's english class at the fritz
carson school in berlin
contrary to last year lessons are
currently given in person in most parts
of germany and not online politicians
have agreed that for now things will
stay that way but the danger of getting
infected is high
i'm a little scared of being in school
because of the corona virus there are a
lot of people here and we change rooms
all the time every day i'm together with
at least 100 people that's no good
especially when you get home and think i
could have easily learned this at home
and be much safer
the phillip family is relieved that the
schools are remaining open despite the
omicron variant the parents are only in
charge of helping with homework the
weeks of learning from home last year
were frustrating
i don't want to watch my own children
all day
help them feed them and also do the
laundry and shopping
i don't want to go back to that it's not
the right thing for our family that's
not my account
familiar homeschooling
learning from home was not a good option
i didn't learn very much and i don't
want to do it again because it just
wasn't any fun
many children feel that way they have
gotten behind and now have the chance to
catch up and see friends every day
deciding factors in keeping schools open
despite rising case numbers local
teacher ryan plougher would prefer a
compromise from last year he liked
flipping back and forth between life and
online lessons working in half groups
and alternating between learning from
home and learning from school can be a
compromise between
epidemiological needs and the needs of
the students to learn so between the
safety of
the pedagogues and the safety of the
children but also their need to learn in
school
whether schools will remain open despite
rising case numbers is up to germany
states to decide as far as education
goes they have the final say
covet infections often seem to be mild
in children
but do children also get long covered
with symptoms continuing for many months
our science reported derrick williams is
here to answer your questions
this week's question comes from monica
aiken
[Music]
can you tell us more about the effects
of long covid in kids
upsides in the pandemic have been few
and and far between but one of the few
is is that at least
children are less likely to experience
severe outcomes from an infection so
they don't often end up in hospitals or
worse
but that doesn't mean that some kids
won't eventually pay a price for it for
contracting covet 19. earlier in the
pandemic
expert estimates differ pretty widely on
on what percentage of children
develop long covet but but researchers
in the field now
think that the numbers uh while
significant
are lower than some early guesses a
larger study from last fall discussed in
the british medical association journal
the bmj for instance
found that roughly one in seven kids are
still reporting symptoms over three
months after a covet infection
like in adults the spectrum of
long-covered symptoms in kids is also
pretty wide
one very serious possible long-term
effect is called
multi-system inflammatory syndrome in
children or or misc which can lead to
organ failure fortunately
it's rare for example there have only
been around
six and a half thousand cases of it
reported by the centers for disease
control in the u.s
so far
recently
the cdc also published the disquieting
news that
rates of newly diagnosed diabetes were
higher in children who had covid
than in those who hadn't which was in
effect already observed in adults
more common effects are often but not
always
similar to those reported by adults with
long copic symptoms they can include
fatigue or or breathing difficulties or
or headaches and of course
changes to the sense of smell or the
sense of taste
neurological symptoms like brain fog
or or difficulties concentrating are
also widely reported in kids just as
they are in adults
it's important to say however that that
pretty much all of what we know about
long coveted children
is based on research that was carried
out
during the delta stage of the pandemic
or even earlier
we still know little about the potential
long-term effects
of an omicron infection it just hasn't
been around long enough yet
to determine them
[Music]
infections are soaring again in india
driven by omicron but officials are
optimistic this wave won't be as
devastating as the last half of india's
1.3 billion are now fully vaccinated
and the vaccine drive is being expanded
to include a booster shot for healthcare
workers and high-risk adults and a first
time shot for teenagers over the age of
15
we visited a vaccination center in new
delhi
[Music]
finally it's their turn
india is now vaccinating children older
than 15 years as well
even though schools are closed once
again as a third wave surges through the
country
these 10th graders hope this will make
the difference
teachers are unable to mentor students
well in online classes and the students
can't concentrate either
once we are all vaccinated we can return
to the classroom and do better in our
studies
i'm happy to get the vaccine now schools
will reopen and i'll be able to see my
friends
learning in the classroom is much better
than it is online
it's a good thing that schools are
closed right now to prevent the spread
of the coronavirus but they need to
reopen now that we're vaccinated we have
examinations coming up
and it isn't just teenagers who are
excited
health care and frontline workers are
eligible for a third dose as well
india is calling these precaution
roses the vaccine has been crucial for
aarti
and not just because she's giving shots
herself
when the pandemic first struck arthy
sent her toddler a thousand kilometers
away to live with his grandparents in
the state of bihar
to keep him safe while she continued to
work in the hospital
it's only after i got both shots that i
called my son back
for a whole year i lived away from him
i only saw him on video calls it was a
huge challenge for me
now with this third dose i feel safer
against omicron as well
there are questions around the efficacy
of india's booster program
most adults in india have received the
astrazeneca vaccine
and the government requires them to get
the same kind for their third dose
but studies have found that mixing and
matching works better for boosters
and that astrazeneca is amongst the
least effective as a third shot
and importing other vaccines is not the
only way out
experts say india is failing to utilize
these
and to explain why i really don't think
we should chase the pfizer and modern
vaccines they're very expensive
uh compared to the vaccines that are
available to us but india is not using
this vaccine which is locally produced
in its boosting program so it does not
make any sense to me for now however
some protection is better than none
this 60 plus couple is happy they are
eligible for boosters
and hopes to soon get the whole family
jabbed
got two grandkids and i'm worried for
them and i would like them to you know
also be able to be vaccinated there
it is they say what kept them out of the
hospital last year
and is most likely their best shot to
keep it that way
next we're off to indonesia which has
been hit hard by curved 19.
the country has registered more than
four million cases since the start of
the pandemic
indonesia has also started administering
booster shots some of which were
produced in indonesia itself
but the country is working on its own
vaccine too
we met up with one of the scientists
involved
[Music]
indonesia's vaccine production in full
swing what you see in these bottles is
the chinese sinovac vaccine the number
one immunization available here
nani nureni is in charge of the process
in a factory in bandung her team
assembles components imported from china
in the pandemic access to covert 19
vaccines has been limited
of course when buying we have to rely on
external funds
if we had our own job to supply our
people then it would be affordable
that way there's more accessibility and
a more even distribution of the vaccines
in indonesia
since the pandemic broke out nureni has
been working around the clock the
state-owned pharmaceutical company is
also hoping to develop its very own
vaccine an exciting process for a
scientist
but nareni says it's also challenging
for her as a mother of two especially if
things don't go according to plan
we have this term called the valley of
death in the manufacturing process
some products here end up just as a
prototype and never make it you have to
bear in mind vaccines will be given to
millions billions of people so they need
to be affordable too
in the end a key objective is to be cost
effective and efficient
[Music]
female scientists like nani nureni are
still a minority in indonesia despite
the fact that at university women in
this field are the majority
eight out of ten undergraduates are
women among the students at the medical
faculty next door
analyzing covet 19 swap tests is a much
needed skill these days but only one out
of three of these female students will
move on to a doctorate degree
there are still a lot of stereotypes
when it comes to professional science
many feel a professional teacher or a
government employee will just make more
money
so many women are discouraged from
continuing their studies as a scientist
[Music]
we need to work on ourselves if we
really love science but the government
should also facilitate and support us in
this endeavor
there could be more funding more
laboratories and learning opportunities
overseas
indonesia has so far fully vaccinated
more than 40 percent of its 270 million
people
but with the arrival of omicron even
more vaccines are needed the country now
launched a booster program early in an
effort to prevent the next wave
so vaccines are still the key to success
in fighting the pandemic
and science has once again confirmed
that young children are naturally better
protected against infection than adults
that's it for today
don't forget to tune in for next week's
covert 19 special until then
stay healthy
[Music]
you